This
is the cow in the American English dialect recordings collection
produced with funding from the National Endowment for the Humanities and the Center for
Applied
Linguistics.
This is tape number forty eight. Sorry to say.
My
idea on to get everything done has to be because I work
salary anywhere so that you know how my own business
and like I work to disarm because Newton people once they're here.
I'm here to write and move to the
stove or they want to get their hero needed so that my
we can start a charity night goes to a Monday.
Sounds like good instead of Friday night Sunday
it's Saturday night and then Sunday and
Monday and Sunday there's usually not that much to do in the first place we got into it
Monday
night we need to be doing this and I
cain't Thursday Friday so they hire me for money to do Wayne do because there is
a variety I just can't I'm too busy I get the
show I keep to stay
happy between doing that and I hope it goes got to go head to
the. Yeah I have I.B.S. or genial right now but
I have planes to go away you know silver Do you need some taking a vacation and so at
that I'm not going to take
all the late Friday and even damaging to
T.V. but Fridays already don't need a comment back to the song
Time or Tonight I learned to
even write a G. similar I said when beyond
taking vacations.
I said I do but
I said I'm ready for this I played
late
fees from my certain customers that come all the time that you
can't. If you're on
a windy day today and
Thursday and Friday and Saturday on the
radio in the hills over
by the
don't
need to assume he likes the place and then they go by Has he didn't
before he's had a couple guys been paid late
today is encouraging to find out.
Yeah it's Wiley's team owner of the once nice to deal just the behind the
or C.F.O. last Thursday don't
want diarrhea storage
economy. There's a clock and you have people
coming to the club in the morning.
I started reading before I had my show and they
are like so over the summer we started saving the only R.'s forty
eight
to four. Except I think it was to do I know
all that I know Joy an old is for sure and they would always send it to you to be get out or
earlier
and they used to think seven was a girl and I vote. You know seven
for the old peer
is you know that not that
all the people around here get all
beautiful and I have a
regular and she like
a former No but she's an elderly woman she's used to get she had over five
o'clock league or less whether she had to go to work or not she'll always get
sober and you don't mind getting I'm not crazy about it and
I know Joy when I get over as it is only one
morning out of the week I get I have to go but for the
whole but the last thirty four
Fridays I stored it seven thirty in
the morning and on a
Thursday and the rest to the. If I do have that in stock before night.
If I don't have to sometimes divide two other choices we'll put Not
this week I came to Des Moines day and we thought I need to do you know because I'm going to be buying
a Bible school. You know nine to eleven thirty two mornings
here but then just pushing everybody into the a commune but I have no regular been
coming to do the way except this way
in every other Wednesday I go
to the new place and
I'm watching said I'm
in by danger joy and I will become
so i have to do that before I go back and then I'm going back to Cheney can do that and then come
back and work
again for
wages or even Hayes a mile
is just what I cited it's close enough in the window when it snows I
can because I'm deadly afraid of driving.
So if I don't have to
eyeball back. So it's
not just on one of these back streets. Faqir is used to being
able to get
home and years ago before my time in the cigar
factory
and then of the
saw the two of the two men this is before the cigar factory
then
of my grandfather full of the building and now a cheek. It used to be a
chicken and like ten years ago. Then for a long time the same
day and I
started with the hairdressing
thing I wanted my own
shop but it was a state law is it has to be a certain amount you know a certain length
and everything else and he said I can have one of the downstairs for
show so I grabbed the J.S. to refix it
of four years
ago he said do you work and if
you begin No I could
at the time one over here for.
Because they knew the so much hassle that we had to do and I think they're just trying to
do
is do what I can by going
to get a little rowdy back there
some the kids a day get
going for one league it's a little odd I knew somebody the other week says they
drew Peyton the blues into a
page whose weekend they saw me they did you hear of the blue I
said
when Thursday morning I said I never even heard it but is that
there's dryer is on it as it were but we really need a shop at the time and this is a three to four they're
all told in a one hundred No wonder I didn't hear
you
get
in from Tuesday to Saturday Night Live. What do you when you're
doing it in Bible school when the kinds of
things you just working on a project like as a
media pitch or
to see the
see the split peas for
the believe watermelon seed for the
bee and bird seed for the truck.
I was working on that late at night my grandmother had a sniper sober. So
the replay of the of other people to help clean you know so I
said I'm going to I smoke in the other room I got most of it don't that I don't have to do
it tonight because I knew I needed by Tuesday only go to just to be back at church.
So I was doing that today
and tomorrow. I said I'll teach two to
D.S. and the other girl is helping just going to teach when dishonesty employed here
on Thursday Friday I will be there and when Dan will be there right away in the morning on the
least listen to
her. So that's going to keep me
busy as that woman really appreciates you doing. It's about a year
and. She can shed a
few. The
longer
I'm
sure
we should see somebody reach the eyes
of her relation and then she likes to new what I
did this time and
the children as well generally going to be she likes to hear
this doesn't
doing really give her something that is think of besides she always seems
to
relieve pain.
Well
why not I never tried it before. So says. I can
you
know and then we started a
cycle then you just take all the curlers and stuff.
And
here is Tuesday I said everything.
So I can just grab it because usually when you do what I am you know lotion
and I just grab a
with
me and
just
talking that I can usually figure out most there are so I usually
or
time. Because if not I just.
Yeah. There she says and she told and then I told
them that I don't get away and no one keeps a mother going to go. Well
I'm just done no I'm not sitting down I know I won't go so I never sit on her i know
i'll never get
all the fun and the afternoon she sits and watches involved
with to then usually because I don't get a change
unity does
she fills me in what happens with life to
relax because I always get up by
this by two thirty in a dude is usually a good time before like
a lot of people around here work from three thirty or is when a lot have to come because they want to hear.
So then I sort of work at my get to
thirty people that don't work
but a lot of people around here
do I sorta get
before the evening when the story goes a lot to my work
and you need
therapy because of one
people who need to three thirty one to know what you do you go
by appointment. Yeah.
Where did you learn. I mean raiding the school
commanding. Allegiance day's news believe how long it took me.
I waited six days a week so I could get down
on and it took me I just figured it out later the getting to
me is in the show to do like
graduated beginning of
June to the day or two that I started duty school.
One of those things you have to learn and what did I have to do into the school. I can't
imagine Well the first three hundred five days alone on a first three hundred
hours you can work on people. You gotta work on I don't
mean just a little a you know it's a boss. It's a bottle
I'm like so I
hate. And you give it a
haircut to use I when you start the thing
is fairly low and till you get finished it's
so short you can already do it easy with
it and you say to new coat it is
that real hair or is that here but it's not like it's in child
so night hate it's not like CARE are
so worse. I'm working on a human Haiti's good compare if
you can survive working on that
single survivor anything I knew we had stored in
the song and it was in the fall and before. Then what they do is
like by state oh it's three hundred but I knew they didn't need to do
is what they call the
cleaning that they don't buy like a regular beauty
shop and they were calling people
like and made the paper deal my mother I do when I
leave don't
even see us it's to all and we were doll in hand to get your hair done.
It's a lot cheaper than going in a
shop and you people coming you know and then you know but I mean they take the
risk you know if you don't know what you might look like to get done with your teacher is logging
on by the
home and that's why as Durham in the fall of the years and
I once I got out
and I was working on the
floor then they said if you want to come in Saturday you
can do to get more hours invite all you can put forty hours in a week we were
only
getting going five days a me. You only got thirty five or the needs of
the seven hours a day so I used to good on
Saturday mornings and then put five more the
in and you had accumulated hours before you could graduate
that you have to file all put into these twelve one hundred fifty
or they go by are they don't buy you have a three year
timeframe to get
daddy's. You have to get a part
of me and that through three years that you're going
to school type thing
because what an evening they work during the day and then just to evening.
Good
evening but trace it out to do
the year to get it done right do you have a job and I just went
to school and then I started in June was new a figure of
speech because I wanted to get finish to the label state board daily
and then or even time or a year.
What was that like to visit her for a few
duties one to call Dr Siegel part in a written
part and try to
go to the nine of ten through you should
a Jew have to go into vide like you would in a shop
like here putting Happy
Feet googly the P.
girls used to go out massage
and be shows which you don't even do not on here you don't do that.
Thank goodness.
Managed to do that on a down again
you know I took my mom
all you got to take a lot. You know you gotta take a model with
the right thing apart and I did
your
mother you know you got to find somebody who is willing to go along and goes.
I don't know who was more nervous at the mirror I was a nervous wreck but she was just as nervous
as I will
is oh oh my gosh. So to get to
take my evil board out of
the finish to C.T. The moment you go to finish a month with the month
before and I thought the winners you have so much to do and I was
driving you.
So I thought it would your the to me and they were.
His newest baby right. And we hardly had any snow that we know so I was in Luckily MS
I didn't miss any cool day over the summer I had if it's the year that I
miss the
slowed and I
miss the movie came early
last Thursday to get ahead in reading the
days that we really tried this was already and we couldn't get
a game done due to an E.G.D. day in
the cold because we got down here to date when somebody
said last week guy and he
turned
to his mom called me and I said
just do the I close and I said I have real easy days I says to him.
Was it ourselves Dave is him of the
car stuff and we go to break to come
who we started that you could feel it they were only that
he goes on when
then
Friday. We call her early in the morning. No
other way on down. I say we get it reading
peeper and one by Paisley used to travel on had four feet of water
all my color up by said to get it we're not going anywhere this
morning around here it wasn't that
bad I was going to ask you what was around here along here there
wasn't the following
year as you are not a rating
that we had to really condors all in one to dig in to do
the most it would have to be Tuesday Tuesday and terrific
Saunders And we had one hell of a flu
here here in the meadow I don't
hear anything a chicken house went down
to a couple pulled in a couple of trees followed as a little bit of
a crick down here
and while I do was
lose it. Took everything along as a grain
of amazing energy that
time since I met Agnes it didn't seem that
bad because I know I talked with my new
foreman Fridays and she said you were you doing at home I said Well as
it
is today done never even
go and then meeting a
Monday that he did I won't even
waiting til Tuesday the
leftists come in to see because these are going to use any more
water than you do have to get out
water so we have
all read a lot of our programs
when we had that still so we decided they said maybe by do
you know why water and then
body two times these said no we can start
using water so we didn't do that much from a vine I know five twelve
foot books and I was a body.
Well kind of learning was a did you have to learn the anatomy of the head or
that you have to do proceed
toward things within reason. Well when you're even when you're working on the pricey
call port they come on a few questions while you're
working like like they did
on
the scout the dog just depends who you are and what your inspectors like you
might say
well you know what to know you on now
and still so you had to do the tunes in the Locals in the new blue business aid.
I don't remember now I knew of receipt boards and no I don't I would normally get
a song like remember
but yeah why would you need to remember that you know who cares.
Can you imagine some lady say my phone or
I thought I stand there and say What the heck you call
the grease. But it's
just hard to do it and I think for the read
the record was invaded
as true and
false with a
bar to conform to involves
rugby you have to knew you had to do
that.